des appareils électroniques brûlé sans
protection des poules et des moutons qui
en gère les restes de ses déchets c'est
bien toxiques sont quotidiennement
vendus sur le marché est consommée par
les ghanéens à une dizaine de minutes du
centre-ville de la capitale accra la
décharge de déchets électroniques
d'akbou bauchi est considérée comme
l'une des plus importantes au monde
ils seraient près de dix mille
travailleurs à fouiller les immondices
smartphone réfrigérateur ordinateur
l'objectif ici est de les brûler pour en
extraire les métaux
quelquefois quand je me lève j'ai des
douleurs à la taille celle là si je me
tiens debout
la douleur est plus forte et j'ai des
maux de tête à cause de toute la chaleur
et de la fumée et que nous inhalons
un processus d
sont particulièrement nocifs imposer
sans réglementation ni protection à des
travailleurs clandestins qui n'ont pas
d'autre choix pour survivre l'air l'eau
et les animaux qui se nourrissent dans
la décharge
tous sont contaminés
nous avons réalisé que lorsque les
poulets ou les poules qui fouille dans
un champ prélève des échantillons de
nourriture dans un champ il arrive dans
leur système est invariablement vous
devez vous nourrir de ces poulets et de
leurs oeufs
selon les conclusions d'un rapport de
l'ipn réseau international d'élimination
des polluants la consommation dans ce
loft dépasserait 220 fois le taux de
dioxine chlorés autorisé en europe la
chaîne alimentaire place les gagnants
face à une question de santé publique
cruciale
les principaux risques sont liés à la
contamination globale par des produits
chimiques toxiques comme les dioxines et
autres cela peut nuire aux gens à plus
long terme par une exposition chronique
les produits chimiques peuvent rendre
les gens malades par exemple du cancer
ou nuire au système immunitaire et
neurologiques dopé par une course
effrénée à la consommation les grandes
puissances exporté toujours plus de
déchets d envoi pourtant interdit par la
convention de bâle signé en 1989
prétexte invoqué pour contourner cette
législation
feindre d envoi de production
électronique pour réparation près de 350
mille tonnes de déchets arrivent
d'europe chaque année les états unis le
canada la corée du sud ou encore le
japon ne sont pas en reste un problème
de santé publique qui devrait pourtant
concerné toutes les grandes puissances
le ghana est en effet l'un des
principaux exportateurs mondiaux de
cacao
[Musique]